[MUSIC PLAYING]
We went behind the
scenes of Marvel Studios
Avengers Damage Control.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: Oh my gosh,
guys, I'm Angelique Roche
and I'm here at The
Void in New York.
And I just got an
opportunity to go
through the VR
experience, Marvel Studios
Avengers Damage Control.
And man, I got to be an Avenger.
It was an experience
of a lifetime.
But you know what, don't
take my word for it.
I had the opportunity to
talk to some of the creators
behind this amazing experience.
Let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm here with Dave from Marvel
Studios and Ian from ILMX Lab.
So talk to me a little bit
about where this is set.
Because it seems that this
is after the events of Marvel
Studios Avengers: Endgame.
DAVE BUSHORE: It is said
after the events of Endgame
and purposefully so, I think.
When we were
developing this story,
it was very much
having a conversation
around what are the
things that people have
waited their whole lives to do?
What are the things
people have waited
their whole lives to relive?
Knowingly while the filmmakers
were working on Infinity War
and Endgame and knowing
that fans are going to go,
oh man, this is going to
be a fan favorite moment,
this is going to be a
fan favorite moment.
Let's make sure we take
a little bit of that
and bring it to life over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: You
start off with this moment
with Princess Shuri at a
Wakandan Outreach Center.
Hello, and welcome
to the Wakandan
International Outreach Center.
DAVE BUSHORE: When we're
looking at developing
the story for this, it was what
are the things that make sense?
We're going to have
a of technology
from the Marvel universe
designed by Shuri set
in a storyline post Endgame.
Who would Tony
trust with his tech?
Probably the smartest person
in the Marvel universe, right?
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: And then
having Latisha Wright actually
come back and reprise the role.
IAN BOWIE: It was
a really good way
to make this authentic as well.
Like, when you start out with
something that strong, where
you're going in and
you're like, that
is Shuri telling
me that I'm going
to test her new prototype.
That's a line in the
sand saying that,
no, you're in this universe.
Like, get ready because we're
making this as authentic
as possible.
And on that authenticity,
the same thing for that
was also getting other
actors besides Leticia,
such as like Benedict
Cumberbatch, and Paul Rudd,
and Evangeline Lilly, to come
back and reprise their Marvel
roles, to really
bring this experience
in a way that
really felt like you
were stepping into the movies.
DAVE BUSHORE: As like with
any good Marvel story,
there's a few cameos.
When you're fighting
alongside the Avengers,
anything can happen.
A portal can open and
take you anywhere.
And anybody can show up
and fight alongside you.
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: One of
the cool things about this
is, like, unlike
other VR experiences
that people have done
before, you're not tethered,
there's no controllers.
You're literally walking
and moving in this space.
IAN BOWIE: Yeah, you
actually get to physically
walk through the experience.
You get-- you see a
wall, you can touch it.
You see your friend, you
can high five each other.
You feel the heat when
something's warm around you.
The ground will rumble when
there are big huge explosions
happening inside of it.
It's on a whole different
level when it comes
to that sense of immersiveness.
DAVE BUSHORE: I think
that immersiveness though
goes beyond just the idea of
a physical wall or a smell,
the immersiveness comes from
the idea that what I am doing
is real.
I put my hand out and
I fire a pulsar blast.
You really did that.
You cannot do that if
you choose to do that.
And that's the fun of it, right?
That immersion is now so deep
because of what the technology
provides and what
ILMX Lab allows
us to do with our characters.
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: So for those
who are now just as excited
as I am to now go back
through the experience,
how can folks learn
more about this
and where can they
experience this?
DAVE BUSHORE: Yeah, they can go
on TheVoid.com and get tickets.
It's here till November 10th
at the Oculus in New York.
It's at other locations around
North America for a few weeks
after that.
So hopefully fans
can get out and--
get out and experience it.
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: Guys,
that was amazing.
DAVE BUSHORE: Was it?
ANGELIQUE ROCHE:
That was amazing.
DAVE BUSHORE: How amazing?
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: Like,
I want to go do it
again, like, right now amazing.
DAVE BUSHORE: Let's go
do it again right now.
ANGELIQUE ROCHE: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]